what do you think about uh
sort of feynman's teaching style or
another perspective is
of use of uh visualization
well his teaching style is interesting
because people have described like the
feynman effect where while you're
watching
his lectures or while he's reading his
lectures everything makes such perfect
sense
so as an entertainment session it's
wonderful
because it gives you this this
intellectual satisfaction
that you don't get from anywhere else
that you like finally understand it
but the feynman effect is that you can't
really recall what it is that gave you
that insight
you know even a week later and this is
um this is true of a lot of books in a
lot of lectures where
the retention is never quite what we
hope it is um
so there is a risk
that uh the stuff that i do also fits
that same bill
where at best it's giving this kind of
intellectual candy on giving a glimpse
of feeling like you understand something
but unless you do something active like
reinventing it yourself like doing
problems
um to solidify it um even things like
space repetition memory to just make
sure that you have
like the building blocks of what do all
the terms mean unless you're doing
something like that it's not actually
going to stick
so the very same thing that's so
admirable about feynman's lectures which
is
how damn satisfying they are to consume
might actually also reveal a little bit
of the flaw that we should
as educators all look out for which is
that that does not correlate with
long-term learning
we'll talk about it a little bit i think
well you've done some
interactive stuff i mean even in your
videos
the awesome thing that feynman couldn't
do at the time is
you could since it's programmed you can
like
tinker like play with stuff you could
take this value and change it
you can like here let's take the value
of this variable and change it
to build up an intuition to move along
the surface or to
to change the shape of something i think
that's almost
an equivalent of you doing it yourself
it's not quite there but
you as a viewer um yeah do you think
there's some value in that
interactive element yeah well so what's
interesting is
you're saying that and the videos are
non-interactive in the sense that
there's a play button and a pause button
um and you could ask like hey while
you're programming these things why
don't you program it into an
interactable version that
you know make it a jupiter notebook that
people can play with which i should do
and that like would be better
i think the thing about interactives
though is most people consuming them
um just sort of consume what the author
had in mind
uh and that's kind of what they want
like i
have a ton of friends who make
interactive explanations and when you
look into the analytics of
how people use them there's a small
sliver that genuinely use it as a
playground to have experiments
and maybe that small sliver is actually
who you're targeting and the rest don't
matter
but most people consume it just as a
piece of um like well-constructed
literature
that maybe you tweak with the example a
little bit to see what it's getting at
but in that way i do think like a video
can get most of the benefits of the
interactive
like the interactive um app as long as
you make the interactive for yourself
and you decide what the best narrative
to spin
is um as a more concrete example like my
process with
i made this video about um sir models
for epidemics
and it's like this agent-based bottling
thing where you
tweak some things about how the epidemic
spreads and you want to see how that
affects
its evolution um my my uh format for
making that was very different than
others where rather than scripting it
ahead of time
i just made the playground and then i
played a bunch uh and then i saw what
stories there were to tell within that
um yeah that's cool so your video had
that kind of structure it had uh
like five or six stories or whatever it
was
and like it was basically okay here's a
simulation here's a model
what can we discover with this model and
here's five things i found after playing
with it
well because here the thing is a way
that you could do that project is you
make the model
and then you put it out and you say
here's a thing for the world to play
with like come to my website where you
interact with this thing
um and and people did like sort of
remake it in a javascript way so that
you can go to that website and you can
test your own hypotheses
but i think a meaningful part of the
value to add is not just the technology
but to give the story around it as well
and like that's kind of my job it's not
just to like make the
uh the visuals that someone will look at
it's to be the one to decide what's the
interesting thing to walk through here
and even though there's lots of other
interesting paths that one could take
that can be kind of daunting when you're
just sitting there in a sandbox and
you're given this tool with like five
different sliders
and you're told to like play and
discover things it's like
where do you do what do you start what
are my hypotheses what should i be
asking
like a little bit of guidance in that
direction can be what actually sparks
curiosity to make someone want to
imagine more about it
you